There's the world's getting better or
worse,
is globalization good or bad is the way
we relate to each other?
Seem like simple questions,
but they're answers concealed very
divergent ways by which we understand
the world.
For those who regularly follow this
channel,
I'm convinced that you know that we are
quite optimistic.
Here abouts are planets in general here
at visual politic.
We are convinced and the analytical data
that seems to corroborate this,
but we live in a world that is improving
and will be better in the future.
However,
that does not mean that that on no
problems,
I mean obviously there are some of these
are as serious as this.
We are facing the largest humanitarian
crisis since the creation of the United
Nations in 1945.
Now more than 20 million people across
four countries face starvation and
famine.
Yes,
of course,
there are still many problems on this
planet.
Well,
within recent years,
globalization has become,
in most cases,
the culprit of everything and the
scapegoat for all of our centers.
Unemployment's relocation,
poverty,
inequality.
For many people,
these are the consequences of a process
of global integration,
which more and more people think has
gone too far.
The numbers are quite clear.
Every time a survey has done,
most people think that the world is
getting worse and this is happening in a
way because of globalization.
Do you want an example?
Well,
in 2016 study was published in the
economist that found that less than half
of Americans,
Brits and the French leaved that this
whole process was a good thing and as we
have seen here,
a visual politic,
all this growing unpopularity of
globalization has been exploited in
practically every corner of the world by
all kinds of politicians,
politicians who oppose immigration.
You opposed free trade and oppose
ultimately well,
everything that's difference.
However,
on this occasion,
it is not a matter of political color in
both rightwing parties and left wing
parties.
We find this type of discourse.
Perhaps a good example was the elections
in the United States where we saw how
both Donald Trump and the democratic
primary candidates,
Bernie Sanders defendants in one way or
another,
this sort of speech which can be
summarized in a sentence as
globalization is destroying our society.
It used to be cars were made in flint
and you couldn't drink the water in
Mexico.
Now cars are made in Mexico and you
can't drink the water in flint
since 2001,
we have seen over 50,000
factories in America shut down millions
of workers,
right?
Millions of workers have lost decent
paying jobs,
but then America changed his policy from
promoting development in America and in,
in America to promoting development in
other nations
with political movements that in recent
years have spread like wildfire.
I arena has emerged a widespread
perception that says that globalization
is stopping.
So I think the question we have to
answer here is this,
what is really happening with
globalization?
Are we facing a paradigm change?
Well,
that's have a look.
The break
last seven decades since the Second
World War and globalization has
accelerated constantly.
And with it the movement of people,
goods and capital all over the world.
Awesome.
All these years,
many political barriers to trade have
been eliminated for a company to have
factories or sell products in a country
produced thousands of kilometers away.
Well,
it's become totally normal.
Suddenly wherever you live,
eating Sushi,
pizza and Nachos with molly or even
drinking a heineken has become the most
normal thing in the wells.
Almost a tradition in itself,
like a I didn't come.
There might be a handicap,
no.
Or even those who predicted that
national borders would become a thing of
the past.
However,
perhaps the culminating moments of all
this culture because in December of 2001
when China joins the World Trade
Organization,
that is when China really integrated
into the world economy and became
something of a factory to the wells.
However,
when the financial crisis,
suddenly things started to change
according to data between 2011 and 2015,
the value of the world's exports
plummeted by 10 percent.
This is according to the WTO,
and it's not only that,
according to Mckinsey,
the annual capital movements,
this is stocks,
bonds,
foreign investments or loans collapsed
more than 60 percent between 2007 and
2015 addition the crisis and all those
politicians you consider the trade is a
zero sum game web.
Some wind and others always lose.
Have results.
In recent years in protectionist
regulations becoming fashionable once
again.
From this day forward,
a new vision will govern our land.
it's going to be only America first.
America first
business
leaders are scrambling to adjust to
world few imagined possible just a year
ago.
The Myth of a borderless world has come
crashing Pankaj Ghemawat.
According to the global trade alert
panel that monitors how government's
taken measures that affects trades since
2008,
more than 8,000
protectionist regulations have been put
into play.
Wait just a moment because although it
does seem true that in recent years
international traders lost strength,
this is not entirely true,
not true for two main reasons.
First,
instead of seeing what has happened
since the crisis,
let's take a slightly longer period of
time.
For example,
since the year 2000.
So if we look at what is happening in
the 21st century,
it so happens that both trade and
investments have grown seconds.
While you know what,
in 2017,
globalization is returning with
strength,
right?
In recent years,
there has been a revolution that not
even Donald Trump or Vladimir Putin has
been able to put a stop to a revolution
that will make our world look a whole
lot smaller.
Digital globalization
trade has been around for a number of
years,
but now international data traffic has
exploded in the United States alone.
80 terabytes of data enter and leave the
country every minute.
A gigantic number that is eight times
the content of the library of Congress,
of the United States,
which is one of the largest libraries in
the world,
and all of that's happening every single
minute.
Emails,
skype calls,
social networks.
According to Mckinsey,
international data flow is more
important to the economy than the trade
of goods.
For example,
facebook has just exceeded the 2 billion
active users,
mark off favorite platform.
Youtube breaks its own historical
records every single year.
They may seem too little,
but the truth is that the business they
generate is absolutely huge.
Take another example.
Anytime to have 10 readers of the
Financial Times,
one of the most important economic
newspapers in the world from countries
other than the UK to have Amazon or
Alibaba,
which are full of entrepreneurs from all
backgrounds who are all working to sell
their products.
In addition today,
we can have designers or by video games,
through online platforms and this
friends.
It's only just begun according to Oxford
Economics and HSBC.
International Trade in services will
triple in the next 15 years.
Just taking a look at this graphic.
Okay.
It's
a pretty interesting result.
Don't you think?
These laminates and my husband,
this is one.
That's God.
I see my blood every night
because my brother.
The fact is that if we consider all of
this,
it turns out that the global connection,
the degree of integration that exists in
the world today is higher than in 2007.
Just before the outbreak of the great
global crisis,
the truth is that each day that passes
brings us into a much more connected
world.
Now,
I'm sorry for those of you don't like
it,
but globalization,
it's not going to go away.
Indeed.
It's only going to grow.
In fact,
we'd now like to pose the question,
is it possible that despite politicians
like Donald Trump,
we are at the door of a new boost for
global integration nosotros in a.
It was those
no new sunrise
possible,
that if you asked us how we see the
future of globalization and free trade,
we would respond negatively as we've
seen in this video.
This is what most people seem to think.
However,
surprisingly,
governance,
they don't seem to share that
opinion.
Latin America,
for example,
the breaking down of terrorists and
restrictions is again becoming fashion
cool.
Argentina and Chile side,
the most ambitious free trade agreement
in 20 years,
wallscape took the lead in the creation
of the Eurasian Economic Union in 2015,
which aims to improve the economic
status of the countries that make up
these so called Russian area of
influence.
No,
Russia,
ballerinas,
Armenia,
Kyrgyzstan and Kazakhstan,
not all part of this alliance.
Indeed,
the European Union itself has also
launched its most ambitious free trade
program.
Yes.
Given all this antiglobalization talking
might be surprised to hear that.
Well,
you shouldn't be because the European
Union has just signed a trade agreement
with Canada and it's about to do the
same with Singapore and Vietnam and it's
also made progress in negotiations with
Microsoft as well as beginning to
negotiate with Australia and New
Zealand's even China wants to strengthen
its commercial commitments.
In fact,
it is demanding that the World Trade
Organization recognize it as a market
economy.
You see when in 2001 trying to join the
WTO,
it did so under its economic status,
not market status,
and it was agreed that 15 years later
this condition would be reviewed.
Yeah.
All that time has come.
We're talking about a technicality that
allows the rest of the WTO countries
such as the United States or EU members,
to impose protectionist measures in
their relations with
no,
for example,
anti dumping measures
or to restrict imports of cars
manufacturers in the Asian giants.
China achieves its purpose and is
recognized as a full market economy and
that is something that will happen
eventually we will see how it's
commercial relations with the rest of
the world are going to have another
important step 10
street that people listened to,
a lot of protectionist politicians and
critics of globalization,
but events.
They're going to take other paths.
In any case,
we think this is a good thing,
thanks to globalization and the
integration of peoples in the last 25
years,
we have lived through the periods in
which poverty has been reduced the most
in the entire of human history.
Nor do they view that they the one all
told me to ask
more than a billion people have escaped.
Extreme needs in the middle class has
grown as never before.
If the average life expectancy has gone
up,
ends up as even global inequality has
been reduced.
So anyway,
what we hope is that the next 25 years
are going to be even better and that we
recognize that,
that all political,
cultural and social differences,
but we shouldn't see them as a threat.
And finally,
we'll end this video,
but asking you what you think of
increasing globalization,
please leave your onset in the comments
below as well as in this survey.
I really do hope that you enjoyed this
video.
Please hit that like button if you did,
and do not forget to subscribe if you
haven't already brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday,
and please don't forget to check it off.
Friends that the reconsider media
podcast,
they provided the vocals in this video
that we're not mine.
And as always,
I'll see you in the next video.
These one or my husband,
this one,
it's gone.
I can't
see my brother every night because my
brother's.
He literally,
I am to Y'all.